Apple's new mg Pro and M2 Max MacBook
Pros are here and if you're thinking
about ordering one you need to watch
this entire video because I'm not only
going to be giving you guys purchasing
recommendations for Which models and
which upgrades to buy but I'm also going
to share 10 mistakes you need to avoid
when purchasing we're also doing a
worldwide giveaway of a new Macbook Pro
and Mac Mini and all you gotta do is
subscribe and enable notifications and
comment below what you can do on each
new Mac video we make for more chances
to win and we'll choose a winner live on
February 1st so don't miss out on that
video now as far as the first mistake
you need to avoid don't think you have
to buy the M2 Max chip upgrade the M2
Pro is more than powerful enough for
most people the only reason to get it is
if you really need as much GPU
performance as possible for a 3D
rendering or gaming also the M2 Max chip
is no longer as good of a value as it
was last year in a really odd and hugely
disappointing change the max chip no
longer gets two video encode engines and
two prores encode and decode engines so
because of that it's not as worth it as
it was before for video editors so many
of you guys out there might just be fine
with the M2 Pro chip as long as it has
enough GPU performance for your needs as
for mistake number two keep in mind that
Apple's GPU on the M1 Max model didn't
scale that well so while you might
upgrade to a 38 core GPU you won't get
two times more performance in the real
world so as you get into more expensive
chip upgrades you're losing some value
due to diminishing returns and bad GPU
scaling but hopefully Apple improved it
a bit this year just keep that in mind
now for number three do not buy the 96
gig of RAM model it is overpriced and
absolutely Overkill even the 64 gig
model is already Overkill we've tested
it before and we've shown that it's not
worth the price so most people should
just stick to 32 unless you know you
need more than that for your specific
use case for number four some people
might assume that this new Macbook Pro
comes with other feature updates but no
the design is identical the display is
identical the webcam is the same the
speakers are the same the port layout
everything all the changes are on the
inside with the only other difference
being a new space gray braided cable to
match that model and the new HDMI 2.0
Port which supports 8K displays or 4K at
240 hertz now for number five if you
care a lot about fast charging then
don't buy the base M2 Pro 14 inch model
because it comes with a slower 67 watt
power adapter by simply upgrading the
chip you'll automatically get the 96
watt fast charger which will charge it
up to 50 percent in 30 minutes however
every single 16 inch model comes with
the crazy good 140 watt power adapter
for 50 charge and 30 minutes even on the
much larger 100 watt hour battery so
keep that point in mind for number six
you might be tempted to upgrade to a new
Macbook Pro for the new Wi-Fi 6E and
Bluetooth 5.3 specs but honestly it's
not going to make that big of a
difference especially since Wi-Fi 60
support on the MacBook requires a Wi-Fi
6E router and they're still very
expensive so while it's a nice spec
upgrade don't put too much weight on it
in terms of your decision to upgrade or
to buy for number seven don't
underestimate the 14 inch M2 Max model
because it comes with something very
special this year if you didn't already
know the 16 inch M1 Max model from 2021
actually weighed a little bit more than
the M1 Pro chip model and that's because
they beefed up the cooling system and
the heat sink but they unfortunately
didn't do that for the 14 inch M1 Max
but this time around the 14 inch M2 Max
model is actually heavier than the M2
Pro hinting that Apple probably improved
the cooling system to fight overheating
and thermal throttling which was a big
issue on the M1 Max 14 inch so subscribe
right now if you want to see us tear it
down to find out now for number eight
please do not buy the 8 terabyte SSD
model it's absolutely overkill for a lot
of people out there I've had a one
terabyte 16 inch for over two years and
it's been completely fine for me so I
would suggest that you stick to either a
one terabyte or maybe two terabyte
storage model don't waste money going
all out because it's going to lose its
resale value insanely fast especially
after Apple updates the MacBook Pro
again and also you never know if you're
going to be tempted into buying the M3
Pro or Max version in about a year and a
half so upgrading to 8 terabytes is a
bad idea for literally everybody out
there now for number nine don't assume
that the 14-inch MacBook Pro is
identical to the 16 inch in terms of
features the 16 inch model actually
comes with a couple of bonuses that you
might not know about of course the
display is larger which is obvious but
the added benefit is that the bezels
actually look slimmer due to the ratios
as well as the notch at the top actually
looking smaller for the same reason on
top of that the 16 inch gets a much
larger trackpad which is more convenient
to use and the speakers are actually a
lot better as well compared to the 14
inch as far as battery life the 16 inch
gets three hours more in terms of web
browsing which is great and don't forget
that the 16 inch gets a more powerful
140 watt power supply which also can be
used to charge other things now for
number 10 this is disclaimer if you
already have an M1 Pro or M1 Max MacBook
Pro do not upgrade I don't think it's
worth it at all sure the CPU and GPU
performance is 20 to 30 percent higher
but if you won't be taking advantage of
the extra performance every day it's not
worth it and I would even say that if
you're gonna have to go into debt to buy
one of these new models don't do it the
economy isn't looking so great right now
and the last thing that you need is more
debt just keep whatever MacBook you have
already until everything stabilizes
again and now let's get into my M2 Pro
and Max MacBook Pro buyer's guide with
my own personal recommendations starting
with a base 14 inch model for two
thousand dollars this is going to be the
one that I recommend for people who
usually buy less expensive laptops in
the Thousand to thirteen hundred dollar
range but have decided to finally go for
the high-end MacBook Pro this time
around and that's a great idea because a
feature is like the 120 hertz promotion
in mini LED display which is fantastic I
honestly think that for the common
person the base model with the bend M2
Pro chip is more than enough for 80
percent of the people out there giving
you the snappiest web browsing
performance you can get and enough
overall performance to handle many of
the common productivity apps like Photo
and 4K video editing now people doing
photo editing should also consider
upgrading to 32 gigs of RAM because it
really helps improve performance and
even regular users who tend to have a
ton of Internet tabs and apps open at
the same time should consider upgrading
to 32 as well to avoid any slowdowns
from completely full memory and as far
as the actual chip upgrades I honestly
don't think they're worth the extra
price unless you do productivity work
every day and especially if whatever
you're doing is making you money and in
that case you can probably write it off
as a business expense as well and in
terms of which chip upgrades to make
keep in mind that the M2 Max chip has
identical CPU performance to the spec'd
up M2 Pro chip there's no CPU
performance difference at all the M2 Max
is really there for the upgraded GPU
since it has double the GPU cores so if
you're a programmer who needs a lot of
CPU performance the M2 Max will do
nothing for you compared to the high-end
Mt Pro do not upgrade to it just simply
upgrade to the spec'd up 12 core CPU and
that's it which will be a must for
serious programmers and others doing CPU
based tasks like photo editing every day
however if you're someone who absolutely
needs more than 32 gigs of RAM like Anna
on Twitter who trains neural networks
and needs 96 gigs in that case Apple
forces you to get the M2 Max to go above
32 gigs of RAM so you're gonna have to
pay for that and on the other hand if
you don't care about CPU performance
like for people doing 3D rendering or
Graphics based video editing you're also
forced to get the 12 core CPU that comes
with the M2 Max but it'll definitely be
worth it since you're getting double the
GPU course and if you're a gamer you
absolutely need to get the 38 core GPU
since graphics performance is everything
for gaming but honestly 32 gigs of RAM
will be just fine for gaming so don't go
above that now if you're a video editor
3D video renderer gamer photo editor or
anything that relies a lot on the
display then I would recommend the
16-inch model because the extra screen
real estate gives you a huge advantage
and makes it so much easier to do your
work and on top of that the 16 inch
model is also great for watching movies
and shows because the display is more
immersive and the speakers actually get
a lot louder and better so it's worth it
so there you have of it there's my
personal buyer's guide for the new
Macbook Pros and if you'd rather get an
M1 Pro 14 inch for only sixteen hundred
dollars you can use the YouTube tagging
feature to check it out so click the
circle about to subscribe and don't
forget to comment to enter the giveaway
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]